this session was laid on fairly recently
so those of you that have come I
appreciate it and and I'm looking
forward to having a chance to kind of
give you at least a little window into a
way of looking at health care both in
advanced economies as well as in
developing economies that that hopefully
will kind of stretch and pull and prod
your perspective and you're thinking
this is uh as all of you know healthcare
is a really important really complicated
really complex subject and one can get
one can spend a whole career on one
little piece of the problem or or of the
issue of health care but what I've tried
to do is something perhaps foolhardy
which is to try to come up with a really
a fully systemic view of the question of
health care delivery and the kind of
central phrase that tries to capture
that as the notion of value based
healthcare delivery and I'll talk a
little bit about what that means in a
minute what I'd like to do is start by
giving you a bit of an overview of the
kind of basic concepts that underlie
this body of work and that will take
hopefully not too much more than 15 or
20 minutes those basic principles really
apply in any setting vast economy
developing country these are what I
consider kind of underlying principles
and then I'd like to take the second
part of the broadcasting portion of this
session and talk about global health not
out of the being a deep expert in global
health but I have spent the last three
or four years getting fairly deeply
involved in global health delivery
systems and there's a whole there's a
whole project at Harvard called the
global health delivery project which
involves many many folks most of whom
they are in the School of Public Health
in the medical school and I've been
trying to help work with with that group
on this topic so I'd like to give you a
little bit of a flavor for what that
work is starting to reveal and I'd also
like to
I think my number one job today is is to
get you to actually look further we're
not going to be able to cover today the
richness of this this topic but
hopefully I can get you intrigued enough
that you'll look at some of the
additional books and articles and case
studies that are growing out of this
work that that's that's really the goal
today it's kind of motivate you to dive
in further so how do we think about
health care really from holistic
perspective how can we sort of start to
get on a different path in terms of
breaking through this challenging
question of reforming health care well I
think I think at least our point of view
is that that you know the starting point
you know for any ultimately successful
health care delivery system is is
universal access you know we you know we
can't ultimately succeed in health care
unless everybody gets health care unless
everybody has access to care so I want
to go on record and say we believe in
universal access we believe that that is
a fundamental goal in healthcare and a
lot of other countries have actually
achieved universal access we have it in
this country but really the our ideas
really start from the perspective that
really that's just the beginning and as
hard as access is it's not actually in a
sense the fundamental problem the
fundamental problem is held in health
care is actually the value of the health
care that we actually deliver it's not
getting people covered in spending money
it's actually what we get for all the
investment that is being made in the
actual delivery of care and and the
fundamental question is how to
dramatically improve the value of
healthcare delivered value being defined
as the patient health outcomes per
dollar spent patient health outcomes how
well the patient actually does what
health they're able to achieve and
sustain and then the per dollar spent is
is the cost involved in actually
delivering those outcomes and we believe
that value then becomes the central
fundamental goal that must guide any
progress
in truly reforming and improving health
care we've got to improve the value we
can't just provide access we've got to
fundamentally improve the value and and
so the the quest that we've been on is
is how to think about a health care
delivery system that would maximize the
value and keep improving that value over
time what would that kind of system look
like what would it it's essential
components be what are the kind of
underlying principles that would guide
the design of a high-value a delivery
system that's the real question that I'd
like to talk with you about today first
in general terms and then in terms of
thinking about global health in
resource-poor settings now in order to
create a high-value cellco system I
think the first the first kind of chasm
that you have to confront is the chasm
that we can't do it incrementally the
problem with healthcare delivery is that
we have to make fundamental structural
change we can't just make incremental
improvements on the system we have today
how do we know that because we have been
making incremental improvements over the
last 10 or 20 years and those
incremental improvements haven't really
made a big difference in fact they have
made almost no difference at all the
problem we have is the current structure
of healthcare delivery and i'll talk
about structure a little bit later the
current structure is a legacy structure
that we've inherited from bygone years
in a very different context you know 30
or 40 years ago there wasn't much we
could do in terms of health care there
weren't many drugs there weren't many
procedures there was very little
technology you know you know 30 40 50
years ago mobility of individuals was
much more limited than it is today and
that's one of the reasons why we have
such a local model of health care where
the presumption is that you will go to
your local hospital in that local
hospital will take care of you in that
earlier world the structure we have
today you know kind of made made sense
the structure that we have today is also
a reflection of how physicians
medical personnel are trained in
specialties it in silos and again one
understands why we have that that
structure but what we've come to believe
is that if we don't change that
fundamental structure grafting on
incremental improvements in in patches
will will not ultimately produce success
what's an example of an incremental
improvement well you know here's just
some of them here on this slide you know
we have all kinds of safety initiatives
and you know care pathway projects and
disease management overlays many of them
have produce very disappointing results
the reason is that if you don't change
the basic structure how you organize
care who works with who how they're paid
and how they're motivated actually
adding these patches will not ultimately
succeed nor can unfortunately we
delegate to the consumer the
transformation of health care you know
we've had this consumer driven health
care movement of course we want to have
inform patients and of course we want
patients to be engaged in their care but
the idea that if we just make patients
pay more money they'll somehow magically
transform the healthcare system is is a
complete completely unrealistic it can't
happen patients can't coordinate their
own care patients can't deal overcome a
dysfunctional system so fundamentally
the challenge then is is how do we
create a vision for what kind of a
structure would actually deliver a high
value and then then we can make
incremental improvements but at least
we're making incremental improvements
towards a kind of a fundamentally robust
long-term strategy and that i think has
been one of the problems in healthcare
reform for these many many years is that
we're really not understood what we're
looking for what the ideal would look
like and therefore we've been kind of
making incremental improvements based on
where we are today the final thing that
is very important part of my work on on
health care given my background as a
strategy professor and a competition
expert is what's the role of competition
in the health care delivery system
and when you use the word competition in
health care there's a certain percentage
of any audience that just kind of goes
the that's a bad that's that's wrong you
shouldn't have competition in this field
this is not a field where competition
will work I understand that reaction
because competition has been very ugly
in health care competition has actually
probably made the system worse rather
than better what's the problems and the
structure of the system that we've
inherited we have a system today where
the financial success of system
participants is disconnected from
actually the success of the patient if a
provider gets paid more for doing more
stuff if a provider gets paid more for
doing complicated stuff than simple
stuff then we have a disconnect between
what's in the interest of the provider
and in the interest of the patient not
that physicians don't regularly for
professional reasons do the right thing
but we're creating a disconnect when
health plans can make money by selecting
out sick people and passing cost of the
consumer and higher deductibles and that
and that's a that's a way that they can
succeed that actually doesn't actually
benefit the patient at all we have a lot
of competition in health care which is
which is what we call kind of zero-sum
competition it doesn't create actually
value for the patient and one of the
fundamental challenges in health care is
to align competition with value for the
patient and so the question is how do we
actually do that choice is good
competition is good it should help us
more quickly get to where we want to go
but we've got to change the nature of
that competition at Etta very at a very
basic level so how do we actually think
about a high value health care delivery
system well let's let's get at some of
the really critical principles first of
all what is what is what does value
really mean and here a value when we
talk about value we're talking about
really the full set of patient outcomes
over the whole care cycle for their
medical condition so say you've got a
patient with cancer when we're talking
about outcomes we're talking about how
well that patient does looked at over
that whole process
care not just the outcome of a
particular procedure or a particular
inpatient stay or a particular episode
in the longer care cycle so one of the
problems we have today is to the extent
that we do measure we we measure too
short and increment in the care process
and we're therefore we're not really
measuring the full true outcome that we
really care about on the cost side costs
are the total cost of care for the
patient's condition not the cost of the
individual interventions one of the
fundamental problems in health care
today is we focus too much on the
individual interventions and trying to
beat down the cost of those rather than
think about the total cost of the full
set of interventions and in global
health this this is very vividly
important but you know we may be that we
want to spend more on certain kinds of
counseling and visits because then we'll
save money later on because we won't
have the emergency room visit the
hospital admission we can't think about
the cost of each service and just think
that cost is the sum of all those costs
we've got to think of costs as the kind
of systems cost of really the whole
cycle of care again this is a
fundamental point in in global health as
well and we'll come back to that in a
minute so the question is you know what
what are the key levers what are the key
choices that we make in order to
maximize the value how do we think about
that well in order to maximize value the
first thing that we I think we discover
from really looking at the literature
and also just common sense is that if
you're trying to drive up value really
the most powerful way to do that is to
work on the numerator not the
denominator to actually drive up
outcomes rather than get preoccupied
with cost and of course what we've been
preoccupied in health care lately we've
seen do we define the problem is it's
too costly and therefore a lot of the
efforts have been on cost control you
know how can we reduce the number of
images ordered how can
we you know kind of avoid the wasted
costs rather than ask ourselves the
question what do we need to do to really
drive the outcomes up and the reason
that driving out comes up is so
important is because of course outcomes
are what we all care about how healthy
did we get how much of our health was
was retained or or renewed but but but
we also by improving outcomes we
actually fundamentally reduce costs in
the long run the only way to really
reduce the cost of health care is to
improve the outcomes you can you can
beat down the cost of providing services
but that's never going to ultimately be
the road to success the way to actually
reduce the cost of health care is to
actually you know detect diseases early
so you can deal with them more
efficiently get the right treatment to
the right patient you know many cancer
drugs that ten percent of the patients
respond you know it is not the price of
the drug it's getting the ten percent up
to twenty percent or thirty percent or
forty percent response rates it's it's
it's treating earlier in the cycle of
disease it's getting the treatment to
happen quickly so you don't just stretch
it out because time is money in terms of
the cycle of care and so on again we
have a lot of people in healthcare that
think that that that that good quality
is expensive that have to get an
excellent quality you should pay more
and that's absolutely alice in
wonderland good quality is cheap you
shouldn't have to pay more for high
quality actually the people that deliver
high quality will actually make more
money because there'll be much much more
efficient and there's copious evidence
of this and yet we all think that
technology is the enemy and that's
what's driving up the cost and and and
it's distracting us from what what
really needs to be done we not we
haven't today engineered our healthcare
delivery system around outcomes and
exhibit a is that we just don't measure
outcomes how can we have a healthcare
system that delivers good outcomes if we
don't measure outcomes and and and this
is kind of one of the central pillars of
what has to happen in any health care
delivery system is it's going to be
successful so
as we're going to try to drive value we
have to focus on the outcomes not just
on on the cost now to make a very
complicated story short in order to sort
of create a high value delivery system
when I talk to a management team of the
cleveland clinic or the mayo clinic or
any other of delivery organization
basically there are six fundamental
agendas in restructuring delivery around
value so let me give you just a little
tiny bit of sense of what each of these
agendas are and why and then we can kind
of talk a little bit about how we can
apply the same thinking in the context
of global health the first agenda and in
some ways the most complicated is
actually to organize care around the
patient not around the specialty and the
service being provided and this is the
concept which I call integrated practice
units and so let me let me try to I'll
just I'll describe that in a little bit
later now the integrated practice unit
concept where we integrate care around
the patient's needs applies of course
very clearly to specialty care for
cancer care or or diabetes care but but
we also find that the same principles
are fundamental to really improving the
care primary and preventive care except
here the the kind of central organizing
principle is not the the patient's
medical condition but actually the the
patient population that we're trying to
serve and I'll come back and talk about
this a little bit later number two we
have to learn to measure outcomes and
costs for every patient right now we
rarely do this and and and on the cost
side I know of but not a single Hospital
in America that actually can measure the
total cost of for an individual patient
when you talk today's healthcare
delivery organizations they can't
measure cost what they can measure is
charges they know how much they build
they don't have much know how much it
really costs and they can't accumulate
costs for an individual patient they can
calculate an average cost for all
patients for
for the operating room time but they
can't actually figure out how an
individual patients cost was accumulated
and that means that we have we lack the
really fundamental insight with which to
really drive value number three we have
to change the reimbursement model around
what we call bundle reimbursement think
of bundle reimbursement is a technical
condition and then let the experts
decide how to use that pool of money
best to actually deliver the care rather
than the system we have now where we
decide how much each service is worth
and then we pay based on how many of
those services are provided the current
system is really misaligned with value
for the patient a bundle model actually
is the way to create the best possible
incentives for everybody to deliver the
highest value I you know fourth
principle we have today the delivery
organizations are basically
Confederations of stand-alone largely
separate units you know if you go to the
Mayo Clinic and and you're standing in
downtown Rochester looking out over the
horizon you will see that there are
other hospitals owned by the Mayo Clinic
that a regional community hospital but
even at the Mayo Clinic those regional
community hospitals that are owned by
the Mayo Clinic are completely separate
they do their own thing they have their
own departments there's no connection
between the community hospital and the
downtown hospital that is very typical
in healthcare delivery we have a lot of
little standalone institutions that all
see their job is providing pretty much
all the same services to their local
community and that model is so
guaranteed not to allow a high value of
care number five we need instead of
having locally constrained organizations
that provide services only in one region
or one town we have to have excellent
organizations that can then spread
service delivery across large swathes of
geography again the the health care
industry is is is really an outlier it's
been crafted in this local mop
where every community has its own
community hospital and maybe is some
academic medical centers and each of
those is basically a completely separate
unit and they ma and even if they're
owned by the same entity there's still
completely separate units we have a
vivid case in Boston we have partners
healthcare Mass General Brigham and
Women's are part of the same
organization they're owned by the same
organization they're completely separate
they they don't talk that will
collaborate they don't integrate
everything is local and yet what we need
to have is we need to have our excellent
organizations not just serving patients
in one town or one region but spreading
their excellent services across across
many regions and and and that's
something that's not happening in health
care today but but it can't happen in
the future final kind of agenda has to
do with IT all of you know of course
that information technology and
electronic health records are really
critical to driving value because that's
what allows integrated care that's what
allows all the people involved in the
care of a patient to have the same
information and to not duplicate
information and to be able to
communicate seamlessly with each other
we kind of understand that I t is
fundamentally important but we are still
far from the place where we have IT
systems that really enable high value
care so we'll talk about that perhaps a
little bit if we have time in a moment
these are fundamentally then the six
agendas that underlie the transformation
of healthcare around value let's talk
about each of them just a bit because I
want you to get kind of an intuition you
know what what I've come to understand
is that healthcare delivery is not
fundamentally a medical problem you know
there's a lot of great medicine there's
a lot of great technology there's a lot
of great ideas and treatments and people
in this field are smart people are
hardworking they try hard they're
dedicated it's not about medicine it's
about organization it's about management
this is a management problem more than
it is a medical problem we have more
medical science now than we know how to
deliver effectively in a fish
and the medical part continues to surge
ahead we have all you bright people
doing more lab research and coming up
with more treatments and protocols and
and yet we can't even deliver excellence
systematically across the system so all
of you in this field have to learn some
management you don't have to go to
business school but you have to learn
some management you're trained though in
silos you're trained to understand your
field you're special to your
intervention you're part of the system
more so in medical school than in public
health what we need to do is we need to
get all of you to understand not just
your part but how the pieces fit
together how the dots connect how what
you do connects to how all the other
people do in the in the case of serving
a given patients needs that that's the
fundamental challenge I find it in the
healthcare field health care has has
kind of grown up with a certain
sensibility and a certain style of
research and a certain model of training
and a lot of that's good but it's also
holding back the kind of structural
change that's necessary to 60 leach
Ainge the value equation so to
illustrate kind of integrated care let
me use the case of migraine migraine is
a complicated disease to actually manage
well and the case here is a case that we
teach it at the school on migraine care
in Germany the reason I use this example
here today is because Germany has
Universal insurance everybody in Germany
has access to care everybody can go to
any doctor they want the you know it's a
very great a good insurance system but
the delivery of care is deeply short of
the ideal and my grand care is a
particularly good example in Germany of
care that everybody agreed this was
really some substandard the data on
migraine care in Germany was very
consistent the care is lousy many
patients aren't getting the right
treatment there's a lot of emergency
room visits there's many many days off
of work there's repeat the repeat visits
to the physician because the patient is
not
being there migraines are not being
controlled all the metrics that you
would measure outcomes of care wid were
really we're really awful and in this
particular case a health plan was the
catalyst to do something about it now
that is a shocking development for those
of us the United States in the in the US
the health plans have not been really
catalyst for very much good about health
care delivery they've been really the
retarding force because of the kind of
legacy approach to competing but in
Germany there was a health plan that
said Jean we've got a lot of these
patients they're relatively young there
otherwise healthy you know but there but
their diseases not being controlled and
they're having to go to the doctor over
and over again and they're go to the
emergency room and they're going into
the hospital and they're not showing up
at work and and and we've got to figure
out what what to do so the health plan
found some really interesting providers
in this case a neurology department in
in the town of essen some of you know
Essen and started a revolution in
migraine care in Germany now the
traditional model of migraine care looks
something like this you can see that
each of these bubbles is a specialty or
an intervention as a primary care
physician a neurologist and so forth and
and the way health care delivery today
is organized virtually everywhere in the
world and I've now worked in many
countries is it's organized around these
bubbles and the patient is a ping-pong
ball the patient is kind of pawning from
bubble to bubble to bubble to bubble to
bubble okay and often back and forth and
back and forth and back and forth what
is the sort of key characteristics of
this process number one it's a
sequential process the patient goes to
one bubble they do something then the
patient makes an appointment and goes to
the next bubble and they do something
and then the patient goes to the next
and the next and the next and if the
patient isn't doing well then they go
back to a bubble and and so on and so
forth each each bubble has its own
administrative
structure so you have to make an
appointment with each one separately and
that is incredibly costly the
administrative costs in health care are
not fundamentally because of the health
plans so I'm going to be a little bit
I'm going to be say something nice about
health plan the administrative cost of
health care or have to do with the way
that doctors are organized because you
need 7,000 appointments to go through
your cycle of care and we'll see later
an excellent care delivery organization
you'll you'll have multiple appointments
all made at the same time by one
organization they'll kind of schedule
the whole process for you and the
administrative costs are very very low
okay what else is what else about this
process should we should we know the
next key point about this process is
that every one of these bubbles sees a
lot of different patients for a lot of
different things so so the primary care
physician you know has 2,500 patients in
their in their roster okay and those
2500 patients have every possible
combination of issues and that primary
care physician is supposed to kind of
figure it all out the neurologists
neurologist sees tons of neurological
conditions so they'll have patients
coming in with MS and they'll have
people coming in with four stroke issues
and they'll have all kinds of issues and
that neurologist is going to sit there
and have to see you know one after
another patient after patient with all
these many many different problems that
imaging center is going to see scans
from all kinds of different issue
they'll be head scans and arm scans and
shoulder scans and nice cans and and and
they're going to have to kind of sort
through and deal with all those scans
and read those scans appropriately okay
the odds that you the patient will get
two per individual that is genuinely an
expert on your problem is very low
health care is is is is a game of a
pickup team you get who happens to be on
the schedule you get who happens to be
there not the person who's an expert
we're really interested in whatever
problem you particularly have except in
exceptional cases does the neurologist
isn't are all just interested in
migraine patients may
not maybe but maybe not some
neurologists think that migraine
patients are a neurotic women you know
who you know can't can't deal with life
and so they have these headaches and
they show up all the time literally
across physicians there's tremendous
variation in expertise and interest and
commitment to this particular disease
but the way the current system is set up
you get kind of who who's there you get
a neurology and and that neurologist may
or may not be interested or particularly
excited about about treating your case
okay that model is guaranteed to deliver
low value there's no doesn't matter how
smart the people are it doesn't matter
how hard they work it doesn't matter how
committed and passionate the people are
on that they can't deliver back why
because they're not organized deliver
value because they're not focusing on
doing a set of things that they can
learn how to do really really well and
really really efficiently so what are
the German Germans decide to do they
decided to create something called the
West German headache center what's the
Western man headache center very simple
it says let's not do the bubble thing
let's put the experts that are necessary
and the expertise necessary to deal with
migraine in the same organizational unit
they work there they go there every day
they have offices next to each other and
they only deal with headache patients
that's what they do and there are people
that are committed to becoming masters
of dealing with headaches and migraine
patients okay now if the if those
patients need to go into an inpatient
unit for detoxification then they're
going to go next door into a neurology
unit that's staffed by the same
physicians that are staffing the migrant
center so they'll be a seamless
transition between the outpatient care
in the inpatient care if they need to
get an image to rule out a bad cause you
know for the migraine then they're going
to go get an imaging unit but they're
going to go to an imaging unit that
develops a depth of expertise in looking
at scans the type of
scans that that that these patients in
need need need to be analyzed the
headache center will go through a
structured protocol it will be all the
appointments you need will be will
happen simultaneously on a single day or
two days there'll be a structured sort
of integrated process of dealing with
these patients problems once they get
sort of stabilized and once they have a
good therapy and once things seem to be
clear then that patient will be referred
out to a outside neurologist to monitor
that patient but it won't be the random
neurologist it'll be a neurologist
that's actually affiliated with this
Center that that that shares a common
medical information system that has the
strong relationships and training and
common and common expertise and
guidelines and protocols okay now what
do you think happened when the West
Germans went from this model to this
model well you probably would guess that
the outcomes dramatically improved
instantly I mean within a week the
number of patients having emergency room
visits went down dramatically the the
number of patients reporting that their
disease was not well controlled and they
were they weren't satisfied with their
disease control went went down
dramatically over time it became clear
that the number of hospitalizations and
emergency room visits and repeat visits
went down outcomes went up instantly why
because people that were really
dedicated and focused on this disease
we're actually dealing with a patient
not who they kind of randomly found you
know through the through the process
then what was interesting is after about
six months the costs actually were
higher the reason is that many patients
that were doing poorly which just suffer
and they wouldn't go back and have that
those extra appointments they would just
see we just suffer what what this model
did was it provided a lot of services up
front the patient saw the neurologist
they saw the physical therapist they
had they had psychological counseling
they had you know review of all their
medication history and all that sort of
that cost more than just going to the
primary care physician and you know
having your 15-minute visit this this
was a more extensive investment for the
first six months even though they had
some improvements in cost because of
reduced emergency room stays the net
cost was higher but as of today which is
about two years into this particular
experiment this model is actually twenty
five percent less costly than the model
was before so here we have the great
promise of health care reform the
promise is that we can have dramatically
better outcomes but by taking an
integrated perspective by getting the
patient to people who are really expert
and who have the experience and the
expertise in the efficiency of dealing
with that particular patients medical
condition we can have this wonderful
outcome better outcomes but cost will
actually be reduced as well this is the
transformation necessary in health care
delivery we've got to stop organizing
around the physicians and the services
and the tools and we have to start
organizing around the patient and the
patient's medical condition and we now
have a tremendous body of evidence that
about organizations that do this and how
how to mend ously they're able to
transform the value equation but it's
complicated because most of these people
you know don't work with each other and
the traditional model puts them in
separate departments and they have
separate department and division chiefs
and and and they and they get paid
separately this model involved a bundled
payment the insurance company gave the
headache center a certain pool of money
to care for these patients and said you
figure out what the best use of
resources is so again the making the
transformation from here to here is
something that is is already happening
but it's going to take time
and it's going to take I think a growing
understanding among people in the field
about what the fundamental problem
really is another kind of key idea and
value-based thinking is the notion of
the care delivery value chain the idea
is when we care for a medical condition
we're not only providing a lot of
services in a given point in time but
there's really a whole cycle of care a
longitudinal process in which we're
providing a set of services across time
and not only do we have to integrate at
a given point in time get the right
skills together but we've got to
integrate across time and we need to
create organizational units that manage
this whole process this whole process
rather than organized again around the
individual discreet services or
specialties again we'll see this a
little bit later we can apply the same
thinking to hiv/aids or two
drug-resistant malaria or maternal and
child health we've got to start thinking
holistically and systemically about the
the cycle of care and and the set of
activities involved the big problem in
medicine I found coming from the outside
is medicine is really kind of locked on
an intervention perspective the focus is
on interventions it's on the drug or the
procedure or the scan or or the
particular discrete intervention peep
that's the way people are trained that's
the way clinical studies are done we're
we're focused on the intervention we're
not focused on value which is the set of
interventions that have to take place
over time that that are mutually
dependent you know in breast cancer care
you know it's not just what you do here
that determines success it's actually
all the things you do that collectively
determine success that yes you well it'd
be better if I could kind of get the
mode out of it and then we'll start up
but I see the time so we've got to move
quickly okay so let's move on another
kind of critical point about healthcare
delivery is that and this is really
important for you all to understand
volume matters
if you only have one case a week of
something you can't deliver value if you
have you can try hard but you can't
deliver value you need a certain minimum
number of patients to be able to afford
to have a team that's really dedicated
to serving their needs you need a
certain minimum volume of patients in
order to have the right facilities to
actually serve that patient well so
volume matters and right now we've got a
hyper fragmented system the ethic in
medicine is oh I can handle anything
we'll take care of anything every
community hospital pretty much tries to
do everything and therefore they don't
have enough volume in order to do it
well this is Sweden Sweden we think of
as Nirvana in health care because they
again they have Universal insurance
universal primary care but look at some
of the data that's got the Swedes really
upset and anxious this is the number of
cases per week that the average Swedish
hospital cares for in a particular in a
series of particular areas and you know
let's just take the one on top knee
procedure that's total knee replacement
one admission per week now a good knee
surgeon can do seven of these in a day
one surgeon so that means that if you
have one case per week what's your
surgeon doing your surgeons doing 25
other kinds of orthopedic operations now
in a good in a good total knee unit in
the operating room there's no need for
the surgeon to talk to the other people
that are in the room everybody knows
what they're doing they do it over and
over and over again they're there a
well-oiled machine but what happens when
you're doing an e-1 time and a shoulder
the next time in a laparoscopic
procedure the next time it means that
you're going to be ineffective and
inefficient you're going to have a lot
of complications you're going to have a
hard time building kind of that
well-oiled team that's going to allow
you to double or triple your
productivity so one of the problems in
health care deliveries we've got to make
sure that we where we have complexity of
services that we have enough volume and
that's going to require again a new
model in many systems measuring outcomes
outcomes are really fundamental to
understanding how well the team does in
terms of the health of the patient right
now in measurement we're focusing mostly
on the processes we're measuring God
where is ur in compliance we're
measuring whether the physicians
actually follow the compliance with the
evidence-based guidelines that's
certainly a good step but but ultimately
what will need to happen in healthcare
is we're going to have to learn to
measure the outcomes themselves how well
the patient does and and in outcomes are
inherently multi-dimensional you know
did the patient survived is certainly an
outcome perhaps the most important
outcome but you know but how healthy did
the patient get what a functional status
was actually achieved you know how fast
was the recovery how many complications
were involved in actually the recovery
process in terms of discomfort and
adverse effects you know how long did
the patient's health be how long was it
sustained before there was a relapse or
recurrence or an additional complication
later on right now we are flying the
we're flying the airplane with no
instruments most medical teams don't
know how well they're doing they can
guess and of course they're in Lake
Wobegon where everybody's above average
but but we don't really know and if we
don't really know it's very hard to
actually improve on on many of these
fundamental
metrics we have measured outcomes
systematically in at least two areas in
America one is organ transplants every
organ transplant in America involves a
systemic outcome measurement every
Center in America has to report its
outcomes on every single transplant why
is that because to get an organ to
transplant you you are required by law
to measure your outcomes it turns out
that measuring outcomes isn't that
expensive it did create a revolution it
wasn't extremely complex they figured
out how to do risk adjustment and guess
what happened to the outcomes and organ
transplants over the last 15 or 20 years
they've dramatically improved for
everybody the whole curve has gone up
the gap between high performing and low
performing centers remains but the whole
curve is moved up because everybody kind
of knows how they're doing everybody
kind of knows that they better they
better revisit they better go talk to
somebody else and figure out how they're
doing it better but until we start
measuring outcomes we have lost our most
powerful tool for improving value in
healthcare and measuring cost is an
equally great a priority what's bundle
reimbursement but no reimbursement is a
total package price for the hair cycle
of a medical condition including the
responsibility for avoidable
complications so essentially if you're
getting a bundle price for knee
replacement you'll get a price that
includes the pre sort of the pre-surgery
visits the actual procedure and then all
the rehab until a certain point after
you know three months later six months
later a bundle price means that if you
have an infection then you the provider
have to bear the costs of dealing with
that infection you don't get more money
if there's an infection now there's
sometimes there's unavoidable
complications there's things that nobody
could ever predict good bundle pricing
systems have a sort of have a way of
dealing with us so that you're not
penalized for that a good bundle pricing
system is severity adjusted you know a
complex total knee with a 75 year old
gets a different bundle than a kind of a
simple company for a relatively younger
healthier patient we now have sort of
dipped our toe a little bit in bundle a
bundle bundle payment payment for short
episodes that's what a DRG is but until
we ultimately start paying for the whole
cycle of care we create a real
disconnect with with value and there are
many bundles pilots going on as we speak
there's a tremendous movement in this
direction those either medicine by the
time you really get well into your
professional career this is the way
you're going to be paid because it's the
only way that we can actually align the
everybody's incentives but it's a
complicated thing to work out and
there's lots of details to be learned
about and this is something that all
people in the healthcare field are going
to need to understand it and learn how
to do because again I think it's
inevitable it's already happening
integration of provider systems i think
is intuitively pretty clear growing
excellent providers across geography you
know here's an example from chop
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia
normally number one ranked pediatric
hospital in America chopped has a main
campus right next to you pan hospital
many of you probably know know that area
but you may not know that chop also has
a large network of other or units that
actually deliver pediatric care some of
them are inpatient units those inpatient
units tend to be inside of a community
hospital but actually chop is running
that inpatient unit it's chop positions
and chop staff that are actually
managing that inpatient unit even though
it's in a community hospital that's not
part of chopped in terms of ownership
they have a variety of and that's
represented by these hospitals these are
all inpatient units for both newborn
care and and and pediatric care that
that chops staffs even though in most of
these cases they don't actually own own
the hospital there's another there's
another set of probably a 25 or 30
outpatient units some primary care some
specialty care that are spread all over
the tri-state area that actually chop is
managing itself so to go to chop you
don't just go to the downtown hospital
you can get chopped quality in a huge
tri-state region and what's very
exciting about this model at chop and
and and and why we wrote a case on it is
that the care in all these units is
actually connected it's not that each of
these units is kind of a standalone
thing it's these units are all really
part of an integrated organization so
that if a kid needs a certain kind of
care they can get it in the in the
outline community hospital but in a
serious case there's a seamless
transition to get that child to the more
acute facility there's a there's a kind
of a sense that this is an integrated
network that's getting the patient to
the right place to get the right kind of
care as part of an integrated process
this is still very rare most hospital
systems are not hospital systems they're
just they're just collections of
independent hospitals that are often
very balkanized and then separate and
then finally information technology is a
critical piece of value-based delivery
this slide and by the way these slides
will be posted so you can you can look
at them at your leisure this slide kind
of talks about what are the
characteristics of the kind of IT
systems that we actually need in order
to enable a very high value model you
know some some organizations are getting
closer but we still have a long way to
go and probably the number one
constraint right now is standards we
don't have clear enough standards to be
sure that we're all talking the same
language that we're all defining things
exactly the same way that we're
measuring things with the same number of
significant digits and therefore the
system still are not really able to talk
and compare and aggregate data
effectively that day is coming but the
the task is is still far from completed
now let's talk a little bit about global
health and then we'll open it up so if
we go from America
or Sweden or Japan or Germany and we
start thinking about Rwanda or Brazil or
Peru you know how do we kind of take
these basic ideas and and kind of adapt
them and think about them in these
resource-poor settings and clearly a
resource-poor setting is different
there's less resources the patient is in
a fundamentally different situation than
in an advanced economy and but what is
been very surprising to me and to our
colleagues in the global health project
at Harvard it's just how many of the
same issues apply to global health as
apply to the more general questions in
advanced economies we have in global
health the tendency to think that the
product is treatment that if we provide
the arv drugs then we succeeded rather
than to understand that the problem is
health it's how well the patient
actually does so many global health
projects measure success based on volume
how many screenings how many how many
how many tests how many drug drug
prescribing occurred rather than
actually the value of the services
provided you know how well the patient
actually did we succeed if we get the
patient on ARVs but we don't really know
how weather the patient had a good
outcome because they don't even
measuring in global health just like we
don't measure it in in advanced economy
settings in global health there's a
tremendous pressure to think in terms of
interventions many NGO programs and
other programs in global health are
organized around individual
interventions rather than thinking about
really the whole care cycle for the
patient there's a tendency to kind of
look narrowly to individual diseases the
so-called kind of vertical view that we
need to think about malaria rather than
to understand that many diseases are
really interconnected and so the medical
condition is not the narrow disease it's
kind of a set of related diseases that
that tend to occur together and probably
the most debilitating thing
all is that global health is massively
fragment and the advent of NGOs and lots
of money has just made the problem worse
we have hundreds if not thousands of
standalone programs each of which is
reinventing the wheel people are
passionate they care they're working
hard but we have these little programs
that are completely disconnected with
each other and they're not part of a
system and they're not operating at
anything like the scale necessary to
actually be particularly effective so we
have a very similar set of problems
ironically despite the very different
setting involved so in this is just a
picture that Jim Kim my co-author in
this area you know found and this is
just one country and all the
stakeholders and the entities involved
in the delivery system in a country like
Cannes Ania and this doesn't even
include all the hundreds of other
organizations actually a delivering care
we're not looking at this as a delivery
system we're not looking at it in terms
of integrated care we've got to learn
how to do that so we have as we have
been doing case studies and working in
this area we've come to believe that
that that at least at the broadest level
the global health delivery systems need
to start kind of being designed and
developed with a set of fundamental
principles they really involve kind of
four basic sort of analytical levels one
is the whole notion of the care delivery
value chain for individual medical
conditions when we think about hiv/aids
or malaria or mother and child health
we've got to think not about the
interventions we got to think about the
whole delivery systems for dealing with
those diseases and as we deliver care in
resource-poor settings however we are
going to need a shared delivery
infrastructure in which we can actually
deliver care but but but but in setting
in a setting where we're going to have
to take advantage of the
efficiencies of scale and utilization
that come from sharing infrastructure
across multiple diseases so how do we
design that shared infrastructure in
order to be a good platform for the
actual care delivery itself of course in
global health a fundamental issue is
aligning the design of the delivery
system with the external contacts facing
the patient the patient's access to
transportation the patient's nutritional
status the patient's you know family and
its kind of social norms and stigmas and
so forth in global health it's even more
important that it is in advanced
economies to kind of recognize that that
the circumstances facing the patient
actually have a fundamental impact on
the actual design of the right way to
deliver care and then and this is
something I've been particularly focused
on myself you know how can we actually
as we design delivery systems in
resource-poor settings how can we design
systems that not only provide health
care but also maximally leverage
economic and social development in the
communities in which in which these
systems are operating we tended to see
the there be there to be a competition
between economic development and health
system development we tended to see
these as competing priorities for
resources I think what we're coming to
understand is actually they're extremely
synergistic and that we can leverage our
health system development to very very
good end for economic development if we
kind of understand where those leverage
points are now in terms of the first
level of thinking I think this is a very
busy chart but this is really the
calorie value chain for hiv/aids and
what this says is that in dealing with
hiv/aids we can't just think about a
screening program we can't just think
about a RV program we can't just think
about you know clinical deterioration
programs or hospice type programs we've
got to think about these things
systemically as sort of a set of
interrelated
activities and interventions and and and
this is this is a process of research
and experimentation that it is just
underway we now have about a dozen case
studies of the best a HIV programs we
can find around the world and what we're
starting to understand is that the best
programs are ones that have been able to
kind of get out of the silos and think
about how they can actually provide much
more effective and care bye-bye thinking
more across the value chain rather than
to see themselves as just doing one one
isolated and discreet step again the
time does not permit me to to kind of
delve into the details of each of these
areas but but let's just talk a little
bit about why you need to think about
the whole value chain not just about the
individual interventions you know here's
just here just for four examples now
what we know is that that if we're going
to do prevention well we can't think
about prevention as sort of a generic
task we've got to think about prevention
in the sense of who's actually at risk
you don't create value by by doing some
preventative step to somebody who's not
at risk the way you create value is you
figure out who's really at risk and
putting your resources for a convention
in a very surgical way against those
people that's kind of an example of kind
of how value thinking might affect what
we what we actually do in practice you
know early diagnosis helps not only for
its own sake but it also helps in
actually for stalling the progression of
the disease so well if we can diagnose
early we get a benefit downstream we get
a benefit because we don't have to
really start the expensive therapy until
later if we if we manage the patient
well how we do something earlier in the
process affects us later in the process
you know intensive evaluation and
treatment at the time of diagnosis can
forestall a disease profession it may be
you may seem expensive to to treat
somebody that doesn't have you know that
doesn't need drugs and we just leave
those people to wait until the time that
they need drugs but it turns out that if
do treat them we can create a lot of
value because we can really stretch out
the period before extensive drugs are
necessary and another kind of classic
example of value thinking is if we can
get compliance to be very high for the
first stage therapy we can avoid the
need to go to a much more costly second
stage therapy so we would be willing to
invest a lot in compliance because it's
going to save us a lot of money later on
in the process so things like Cuban
health workers may be a real bargain
because the community health worker who
can watch that patient actually take the
drug and make sure they have it and make
sure they comply will save us the need
to pay for a five times or ten times
more expensive course of therapy later
on again that's that's that's kind of
value thinking but when we're organized
around interventions when we're
measuring success based on volume not
value kind of we missed those critical
points now again we could talk about the
this sort of analytical mind set at all
these levels you know how we design the
shared delivery infrastructure to kind
of maximize value how do we integrate
the horizontal and vertical in a way
that that creates the best possible
outcome per dollar of cost again some
implications just taking hiv/aids up you
know what what are the relevant aspects
of external context one of those things
that are going to affect our success in
actually caring for patients in
providing a care and and what do we know
about the best possible way in which to
deal with these various factors there's
a tremendous amount of knowledge about
this in the global health field but it's
never been pulled together this is a
field of lots of little papers on lots
of independent subjects and there's been
really no way of kind of aggregating our
knowledge about all of these things and
transmitting that knowledge to
practitioners in the field who have to
figure out how to design their systems
and actually provide care in a highly
imperfect world with limited resources
so how can we kind of start
you accumulate our knowledge base about
about each of these factors and how to
best deal with them again here's some
some implications again for the case of
HIV where we've done a lot a lot of work
on that and then of course the the
impact on economic development I think
it's well understood that that healthier
people are necessary for a productive
economy I think we all understand that
if people aren't healthy they can't work
they can't be productive they can't they
can't create a benefit to the economy
but what is less understood is how the
health system itself is a driver of
economic development through the direct
employment but also through the
procurement and through the catalytic
effect that the health system can have
on the kind of critical infrastructure
necessary for enabling economic
development in poorer settings and this
is since I'm an economic development
scholar as well this bridge between the
health system and the economic
development it is something of
particular interest to me again there's
there's there's material written about
this that we can share with you now a
lot of the thinking in global health has
been on public policy what's the right
public policies that will move the
health system forward but I think we've
often gotten the cart before the horse
we really lack a shared understanding of
what a high value delivery system is in
a resource for setting what it would
look like how these elements interrelate
you know what the role of the various
clinics and hospitals and other
institutions is how to see this as truly
a system until we understand what a high
value system looked like it's pretty
hard to set public policies that are
actually going to work and drive us
towards our goals so we believe very
strongly that we start we need to add
another level to the research and
ultimately to the practice in this field
we've got a lot of work going on basic
science and that work hopefully will
continue and hopefully we'll have more
breakthroughs and more progress and you
know people like the Gates Foundation
are pumping you know billions of dollars
in into basic science to kind of improve
the tools available there's a lot of
work in healthcare on on clinical
science on you know what's the proper
diagnosis what's the proper intervention
you know how do you think about that how
do we learn how to do that better you're
really really important oh you know
there's a whole established literature
around clinical trials and and and in
other methodologies for doing this work
there's a growing body of working
evaluation science you know does this
intervention work is it cost-effective
unfortunately a lot of that work though
is is kind of is kind of not very
connected to reality because it's
controlled experiments it's holding a
lot of things constant and varying only
one thing and we know that in real life
everything's always varying and we don't
have controlled experiments and so we
need we need to learn how to deal with
the complexity of the actual delivery so
we believe that there's another body of
work necessary which is what we would
call delivery science which which which
looks at some different kinds of
questions now how our interventions best
delivered how do we look what do we know
from the many organizations in the world
that are trying to do this how do we
know which ones are most effective which
approaches are most effective a very
very not a field in that area yet you
know how can the whole set of
interventions be integrated over time
how do you put these things together how
do you really adapt delivery to specific
kinds of local circumstances what what
do we know about that and then of course
how do we measure value not just you
know how many drugs were prescribed or
or or how many patients were served but
but actually how well the patient's did
and how do we develop new techniques and
methodologies for doing that as I
mentioned before we have a project at
Harvard called the global health
delivery project we have a tremendous
body now of case studies that you might
be interested in these these are the
organizations that now have in depth on
site clinical deep
studies done of what did they do and how
is it going and and and and it which
allow us to really dig into what creates
effective health care delivery models
how do you organize how do you reward
the the workers you know how do you best
reach out and engage patients there's a
wealth of learning out there but we've
never had a mechanism for for pulling it
together so our hope is that that some
of you that are passionately interested
about global health will will will will
kind of tap into this work if you're
interested become part of it we would
love to have a bunch of people at Yale
working in this area as well we'd love
to share all we have with you because we
you know we've global health has been a
field where you know there's been a lot
of passion and and people have viewed
with with great does it have a
tremendous desire to do good here and
it's been a field where kind of let's
call it values have been very important
you know we we have an obligation to
help people in resource-poor settings
get health care but you know Jim Kim and
I in particular my co-author and much of
this work we think it's time to move
from values we care to value we're
really creating great outcomes
efficiently and and that's kind of the
place where where we think this field is
kind of needs to move in the future so
hopefully some of you will be moved to
read some of this material get in touch
with this and and we and we'll look
forward to that